hi
i'm vin diesel and i'm going to break
down some iconic scenes
from the fast and furious franchise
[Applause]
well first of all it's one of the
standout scenes
that did a lot to start to build up the
characters
and the franchise it was a very exciting
time
there were a lot of people on set that
were real
uh streetcar racers that actually
months earlier when paul and i were
doing research for our character we
actually went on
illegal streetcar races that were very
much like that
uh and we actually ran from helicopters
at that time so there was a
energy about that moment to see
all of these racers to see all these
authentic
and um original cars there
to the excitement of getting on the
front line
before we took off and and started
racing
because so much of it was film practical
we were really
driving along that street and thinking
hoping that our car didn't veer off and
hit anybody
what are you smiling about dude almost
had you
[Applause]
you almost had me you never had me
you never had your car working on the
first film with him was
incredible the first time i had met him
um we were doing research for
our characters and that's where we
kind of built our bond i had just come
from directing
independent film so he was very
always very curious of what i thought of
every one of his lines
so whenever he had a line he'd come over
to me and say what do you think dom
what do you think then what do you think
he took a lot of pride in that
that dom bryan relationship um
that meant a lot to him as it obviously
meant to me
ask any racer any real racer it don't
matter if you win by an
inch or a mile that's right winning's
winning
it was the beginning of this complex
journey
that you know in fast and for we were
estranged and we were going to
kind of have to settle our differences
and realize
that we were brothers
that scene was wonderful because it was
representing the dominican republic
which is where dom what has been for so
long
but it also did something else which was
it highlighted a brother that
nobody met in the first one which was
han
you only realize where they you know the
the
escapades and the heights that they've
been doing in central america and south
america
only once you see fast four so i think
that brotherhood was
important to spotlight
especially when you jump cut to fast
nine when you're dealing with a theme
that surrounds a broken brotherhood to
counter that in fast nine to counter
that
storytelling you needed you needed to
anchor that
with another brotherhood that's been
pure and consistent
and that's the han brotherhood
[Applause]
i had decided not to do the second one
and in part it was because i had
i had said to the studio that they
should never make a sequel to this
because if you make a sequel you'll lose
the possibility of this film being a
classic
as you know in the 90s and the 80s if
you sequalize something you were
destined to bastardize it and so i
that was always my fear and
then they had approached me about doing
a cameo um
which i couldn't believe it because i
thought it was very clear that i had
moved on
and i have a childhood buddy of mine
named valentino morales who said to me
dom toroto doesn't belong to you then
he belongs to the world i went what
i mean huh that's not how you're
supposed to pick
uh roles that you play but i remember it
being
very poignant and i remember that
sentiment being very
hitting me like a ton of bricks and
the studio said we want you to produce
otherwise we want that we're not going
to make another fast uh
i said if we approach each sequel
like the next chapter and we evolve our
characters
like you would in episodic storytelling
then i will produce it and return this
down to it
[Music]
that was such a great great great great
great great sequence
any scene that i have
with pablo is
priceless is a gift beyond words
and and when it's a scene that is that
incredible uh
it's even more of a gem
i remember being dropped into this
lake or something and i remember him and
i
having to hold ourselves underwater for
some reason for some long reason
that didn't make sense to me back then
but it was a camera angle for the camera
shots
so uh we're actually having to become
navy seals for this shot
um and then i i remember we had all our
clothes on so they had
a little jacuzzi um and i remember
and i in the jacuzzi with all our
clothes on
trying to warm up so we didn't die from
hypothermia
um and i remember us laughing
and laughing and laughing and laughing
it was one of those scenes that just
what i take away from it was the
laughter and the joy that we had because
we felt like two kids doing the
impossible
toast ghost
money will come and go we know that
the most important thing in life will
always be the people in this room
right here
right now
salute
it's introduced in the first one right
that's that's what was so
interesting about this character i'm
playing this outlaw this tough guy
who forces jesse to say prayer
at a backyard barbecue and although he's
not articulating family yet
he's treating
the group of misfits like a family but
it was cemented
in fast five that's where the idea of
family
really really hit home after fast four
when brian is discouraged by
the verdict by the judge and decides to
take matters into his own hands
and decides to go on the run with his
brother
as opposed to allowing his family to be
broken
so our fast five was when we started to
be bold about this theme of family and
realized that it was something
worth spotlighting you know the idea
that we had this multicultural family
the idea that it didn't matter where you
came from what your race or religion or
gender was
if you were at that table you were
family
and that's something that the audience
has come to expect and appreciate
uh the audience for fast and furious
always feels like they belong on the
screen
with the rest of us
cars don't fly
it is one of the most iconic scenes and
it's profound how we were able to share
that scene together
it was a kind of a culmination of our
our both our character trajectory the
thing i remember the most is
the wondrous and beautiful
moments of filming that with my brother
pablo
that i'll never forget for the rest of
my life
hey catch you good leave without saying
goodbye
i used to say i live my life a quarter
mile at a time
and i think that's why we were brothers
if you
see the scene you can see
that i'm crying before the take and
after the take you could see
uh you can tell when somebody's been
been through it and you can tell when
somebody's
eyes are trying to hold it together and
that's what that was
that was uh maybe one of the hardest
scenes i've ever filmed in my life
because
it was it was so hard to remain
dom in a scene where he's just saying
goodbye to
to his brother on film for a second you
don't know
you know he's in the universe and you
know you're going to see him again
[Music]
but that in conjunction with the realism
with the reality that i would never be
able to see
paul walker again was devastating
it's never goodbye
where's the bridge
no no no
good
well that was new f9 is
what we've always envisioned as the
beginning of the finale
so the stakes are higher
we are uncovering uh
characters you never knew existed in the
mythology
um and all the characters
are beginning to uh fulfill their
character arcs
there's something very cool about it the
coolest thing is that
this character that we met two decades
ago
is still here still present
but now he's a father not just to see
that
happen over two films but to see that
happened over two decades
is really something unique and really
something
that uh the fans
gravitate towards because they know that
these characters are evolving
it's so almost like unlike any other
movie we've been lucky enough
to have films that when the movie ends
you always walk out of the theater
saying
what will happen next it's the only
franchise i've ever heard of that people
walk out of the theater and stop by the
ticket booth and say can i have the
ticket for the next one
yes i spent my entire life in your
shadow
and now
you spend the rest of yours
not today
[Music]
oh
you